let me ask you this question
who is satoshi nakamoto there's
quite a few people who suggest that
person
is you so
is it you no
who do you think it could be i don't
know who it is i
i think if i had to guess it's probably
a group of people
some of which might not even be around
anymore um
you know obviously i'm very grateful to
if this is a singular or a group of
people for kicking off this entire
industry and making this amazing change
in the world
that you know i have the the privilege
and luxury of of being part of in in
some small way in the work that i do
um i think also this kind of focus on
who is
satoshi or who is in satoshi shouldn't
in my opinion matter
so much because regardless of who it is
that in my opinion should have no
substantial significant effect or
bearing on
the functioning or the value or the use
or the
or the security of of of the bitcoin
system right
so i think whoever it is they're
probably better off not
not not making that public and i think
beyond that
whoever it turned out to be shouldn't
matter because it has nothing to do
with how the system is made useful or
secure or anything
else and so i think that's the you know
that's the point of view that i have
now if you were satoshi nakamoto would
you tell me
because you said they shouldn't whoever
satoshi is
you should keep that private so would
you tell it to me
or no we're in some kind of weird like
a thought experiment here if if i was
this guy
um let me think about this which i'm not
by the way i am not
this person but if you were would you
say it
um i think uh
probably not i don't see the i i i think
that they would cause a lot of
distraction
and a lot of weird stuff and so
realistically i don't think it would
help
anybody or even the person who who
discloses it but just to be clear i am
not
and whoever it is i think they haven't
said anything because they don't want
the attention and they don't want the
distraction and they don't want all the
problems from this
and that's that makes sense to me
conceptually
it's fascinating to think if they're
still out there and part of the
the bitcoin the cryptocurrency community
and um it is inspiring to think that
if they're out there that they're not
revealing their identity because it
would be a distraction
that's kind of inspiring that people are
like that just like george washington
relinquishing power is inspiring because
it's ultimately about the progress of
the community
not some kind of ego driven attention
scheme
again very inspiring the humans at their
best are inspiring
you